épreuve phare mais redoutée de ce bac
nouvelle version le grand oral le 22
juin nathan se pliera à l'exercice il a
dû choisir et faire valider deux
questions liées à sa filière les
sciences et technologies de l'industrie
et du développement durable alors le
principe vivante orale c'est en trois
parties donc la première partie on a
notre question que le jury choisit donc
il en prend une b2 après on parle
pendant 5 minutes sur cette question
après on a un échange de dix minutes
là où ils vont nous poser des questions
par rapport aux cinq minutes précédentes
et après ça on parle pendant cinq
minutes de notre orientation là où la
houle et les intervenants ils peuvent
nous poser des questions
le baccalauréat 2021 commencera le 17
juin prochain
la plupart des matières sont passés en
contrôle continu
au programme en plus du grand oral les
élèves passeront la philosophie bas le
bât bon jeu
je prépare en fin d'année là du coup
parce que il nous reste que deux
épreuves parce que le reste est annulé
donc on a philo et on a un grand oral
bon bah philo on révise malgré tout les
textes qu'on a et le grand oral pas faut
préparer ces deux questions plus la
partie orientation les confinant ont
aussi impacter la préparation des
lycéens avec la fermeture des lycées et
la mise en place de 2012 ils n'ont pas
eu l'occasion de faire des examens
blancs pas préparé on n'a pas vraiment
fait doha lancôme ans seulement en faire
pour préparer le grand oral b et on a
fini les cours demain donc
c'est fait à larache en soit on est pas
prêt près de 19 mille autres élèves
yvelinois s'attaqueront à ces deux
épreuves
en espérant que nathan fera partie des
heureux bacheliers de cette année